The Joe Rogan Experience it's
nerve-wracking man because the people
that have that kind of money and that
kind of power they want to maintain that
position and they want to maintain that
influence over people and the best way
to maintain it is to like tighten down
on what people are allowed to do yeah
where they have to comply I mean the CEO
of Pfizer there was a famous speech
where he's giving was talking about a
pill that you would have to take that
sends off a signal to show that you've
taken it and he says imagine the
compliance
no let's find that find where he says
that because it's so bonkers
like compliance like oh God you know
it's comply yeah you're making people go
you so you force you're that word that
term just the thought process behind
that statement is so great courage would
be better
comply like you have no choice
here it says edited to cut important
context
CEO Albert Bora explains so what is the
what is the actual but it's it's okay it
says the video discussing ingestible
pills with sensors has gone viral
falsely presented as an interview from
2022 and edited to cut out important
context one Twitter user shared the clip
on May 20 here commenting Pfizer CEO
Albert borla explains Pfizer's new tech
to Davos crowd ingestible pills a pill
with a tiny chip to send a wireless
signal to relevant authorities when the
pharmaceutical has been digested imagine
the compliance he says now is that
really what he said say
so what does he really say yeah there's
there's what's cut out if he says that
see this is one of those things where
you got to wonder if they're trying to
Gaslight you with the headline
he commented on biological sensors
during a conversation on General
technological advances in healthcare and
pharmaceuticals
so what does he said in response to a
question from the audience ideas to
engage patient he calls the research and
field fascinating says that there's
already a pill approved by the US Food
and Drug Administration it moves on to
describe this pill and where the clip
version seen on social media begins and
he later concludes but of course there
will be an initial cost and someone
needs to invest boiler was not talking
about a Pfizer drug or technology rather
who's describing Abilify my site a drug
with a digital ingestion traction system
right
so that is it okay for the treatment of
schizophrenia acute treatment of manic
and mixed episodes associated with
bipolar disorder bipolar one disorder
and for use as an add-on treatment for
depression adults so he was talking
about a different pill but he was
talking about a pill with a sensor but
the point is it's still the same thing
that is true so they can say well it's
for this schizophrenia or manic so
that's why they that's how they got it
approved but now it's out there right
well now it's an actual technology and
if they can mandate a medication that
you have to take so they mean there's
something else they make it sound good
by oh that maybe that would help those
people but now it can be used on
everybody yeah
so here it says that so it basically is
a biological chip that is in in the
tablet and once you take the tablet and
it dissolves into your stomach it sends
a signal that you took the tablet so
imagine the applications of that
compliance
okay so did he say imagine the
applications of that compliance and then
they edit it to say imagine the
compliance
I think that's what it's saying let's
see him say it here's here we just play
the video yeah let's play the video and
then let's play the video that would be
this one
it is a basically biological
ship that it is in the tablet
and once you take the tablet and
dissolves into your stomach sends a
signal but you took the tablet
so imagine the applications of that
compliance the insurance companies to
know that the medicines that patients
should take they do they take them it is
fascinating what happens in in this
field that doesn't comfort me if that's
what you really said but he's saying so
if you have a schizophrenic patient
right they have to take it they to know
that they did or didn't take their
medicine like they're supposed to yes
but yeah you could use that on anything
then you could use on anything let's see
once they get it you know down the
whatever approved then it's there
exactly yeah exactly and once it's been
applied before they can apply it to
other things and if they can mandate
that everybody takes a medication they
have for health and safety especially if
you have an application now if you have
an application This World Health
Organization digital passport it sends a
signal to your passport and if you don't
you you're not going anywhere and they
just say it's for health and safety it's
all Bonkers yeah and the [__]
headline that they had to that is like
yeah that's that thing that they know
around yeah yeah we were reading this
thing about Al Pacino there's this whole
article in the the type of the article
was Al Pacino it feels like uh reports
are that Al Pacino felt like the girl
Hoodwinked him and this and that and
then below that in small letters after
we talked to him that's not true
so the head so look at this look at this
check out this [__]
here we'll go back look at this
so this is a really special coming at
this time Al Pacino 83 breaks silence to
celebrate 29 year old girlfriend's
pregnancy after claims he demanded
paternity tests because she Hoodwinked
him the actor revealed he and his
girlfriend Noor alfala we're expecting
last week initial reports claimed that
Al was not pleased over the news sources
told Daily Mail that wasn't true which
he has now confirmed then why is it
confirmed it's not true it's still in
the headline right but that's in little
tiny letters yeah below the big headline
that says
break silence to celebrate 29 year old
girlfriends pregnancy after claims that
he demanded paternity test because she
Hoodwinked him yeah claims
claims
by who yeah but that's a headline so
they're allowed to do that just like
they're allowed in that last headline
that's what drives me crazy so what was
the last headline go back I sort of
understand this one because there were a
bunch of claims that he was mad and
they're like he's he's no no no no no no
no not the Al Pacino one go back to the
other headline the borla one what was
the headline that discredited
yeah it's right there and it's not
Pfizer's Tech is the problem okay so
it's but it's new tech yeah whether it's
it's still the CEO of Pfizer talking
about the world economic Forum it was
also in 2018 and they're saying that
this was new in a year ago even if it's
2018 it's still crazy yeah it is it's
still crazy and I get it that it was
pre-pandemic so it's a different thing
and in application for schizophrenics I
understand that as well I know people
that are schizophrenic and I know people
that go off their medication and lose
their [__] mind and it's dangerous
it's weird it would probably when Brody
was off his medication um right there
was a moment when uh Brody was around
the store when he was off his medication
and people were trying to get him back
on it and you know he was really
struggling and it I've seen it you know
so if you had a situation like that
where you could ensure that Brody was
taking his medication maybe Brody would
still be with us I don't know but maybe
maybe he'll be okay maybe but it's also
he's a human being and like maybe you
should just try to get someone to be
with him and make sure he takes his
medication rather than forcing a new
technology down the throats of everyone
for a very small percentage of people
that absolutely have to take medication
or they go crazy because most people
don't have to do that right so to have
that kind of tech available that freaks
me out